despite the MCU is raging success at
adapting their library of comic book
stories to film not every one of their
storylines is well-suited to the silver
screen some stories are too violent some
are simply too controversial or carry
unsettling undertones and a few are just
too dang weird for a mainstream movie
studio
whatever the cause don't expect to see
these tales unfold in the theater until
everyone's run entirely out of ideas and
even then don't hold your breath
The Ultimates the Avengers borrows a lot
from The Ultimates superheroes bickering
among themselves the Hulk going on a
rampage and a large-scale alien invasion
forcing the team to put their
differences aside and come together to
save the earth are all part of the
iconic story and then there's the fact
that MCU Nick Fury is a dead-on
duplicate of ultimate Nick Fury so far
so good but that's about as adaptable as
The Ultimates saga gets the Ultimates
presents a very cynical view of
superheroes ultimate Captain America is
a xenophobe ultimate Hank temporarily
beats his wife ultimate Hulk just
straight-up
eats people Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver brother and sister are
lovers things reach an insane crescendo
when the x-men villain the blob eats the
wasp and Hank Pym responds in kind using
his size changing abilities to get
revenge by biting blobs head off most of
the x-men perish thing crushes dr.
Doom's head with his bare hands and
Manhattan is more or less annihilated it
goes without saying that the whole story
is too dour for mainstream Marvel to put
on the screen people like to root for
their heroes The Ultimates makes that
more or less impossible secret Empire
you might have heard about the
controversial premise of secret Empire
even if you're not a comic reader yeah
that's right this is the comic that
makes Captain America a Nazi
so technically cap was a sleeper agent
for Hydra except he wasn't really thanks
to red skull and some Cosmic Cube stuff
but despite Marvel's claims that doesn't
really make anything better the basic
story is Steve Rogers infiltrates shield
reveals his true nature and conquers
America and hydras name isn't that
uplifting even if Hydra cap isn't a Nazi
by name the parallels are too strong to
ignore because you know Hydra is
basically Nazis
[Music]
we've already had two Hydra filled
takeovers of America in the MCU already
a third led by Nazi cap is pretty
unlikely these days real-life Nazis some
of whom proudly wear Captain America's
gear are an actual problem because of
this secret empire received plenty of
criticism from the comic-book community
marvel's not going to court that kind of
controversy by repeating the plot and
theaters and won't risk tainting one of
its most popular characters for a stunt
count on sins past the Green Goblin
might be spider-man's arch-nemesis but
don't expect Norman Osborn to grace
theater screens anytime soon for the
Goblin Steinhardt fans that's bad news
but there's one silver lining
Norman's absence means there's no way
that spider-man's sins past story arc
will ever get a big screen adaptation
and that's very very good sins past sees
Peter Parker's girlfriend Gwen Stacy
have a brief fling with Norman the guy
who eventually ends her life while
vacationing in France as a result of the
encounter Guin gives birth to twins it's
not only the age difference between Gwyn
and Norman that makes the story so bad
it's not only that Mary Jane knew about
the affair and didn't tell Peter until
the twins appear at his door now it's
that in the follow-up storyline sins
remember'd
Peter makes out with one of the twins
because she kind of looks like Gwen
kissing the daughter of your long-lost
love and number one villain while you're
married to someone else
that's bad comic book readers didn't
tolerate it and eventually the whole
affair was retconned out of existence
chances are movie audiences won't
tolerate it either
Thor Vikings not even Chris Hemsworth's
dreamy smile and strong sense of humor
could make Thor the Vikings work
on-screen as this dark superhero
adventure reminds us the ancient
Norseman weren't wise cracklings
swashbucklers like thor and his comrades
they were hardened warriors with a mean
streak of mild lawn which thor Vikings
rebels in this is the comic that opens
with a Viking horde raising in the
region village and then sends the
invaders to modern-day New York where
they pillage and slay their way through
man hat
as undead conquerors they drive a spear
through the mayor on live television
they block the streets with piles of
severed heads even Thor has trouble
stopping
especially after they snap both of the
Thunder gods arms chain is hammered to
his neck and check him into the Hudson
River the differences between the
violent unforgiving nature of real-life
Vikings and colorful successful fare
like thor ragnarok are too great even if
it weren't Thor Vikings is just too
violent for mainstream moviegoers even
dedicated gore hounds might find some of
the gruesome antics stomach-turning
so nice way of putting it Deadpool kill
a straight Deadpool isn't an entirely
bad guy
but he's also got no problem with
violence he's a mercenary in a world
full of supervillains
so sometimes gore is going to happen
it's just part of the job that's why
he's so popular but there's still a line
and Deadpool has been known to cross it
not only is he obliterated every hero in
the Marvel Universe twice but in
Deadpool killest rated the Merc with a
mouth hunched down characters from
pieces of classic literature and yeah
it's kind of funny to watch Wade Wilson
scoop out Don Quixote sigh balls spread
Tom Sawyer's blood all over the boys
nearly painted fence and torched Dracula
it's also very very dark even for
Deadpool on the page Deadpool's violence
doesn't seem any worse than a
particularly depraved cartoon translate
that story into live-action however and
the murder of everyone in the jungle
book would be positively traumatic
jla/avengers the Avengers proved that
superhero crossovers could work just as
well in theaters as they do in comic
shops but these days interconnected
superhero universes are old news in fact
there's only one big superhero crossover
left to do but it'll never happen
letting DC and Marvel characters share
the same screen would be like the USS
Enterprise dogfighting with the
Millennium Falcon the corporate
overlords at Disney and Warner Brothers
won't ever agree to it even if fans
would literally rip off their own arms
to see it happen that's a shame too
because comic books have already given
both studios the perfect template for a
blockbuster jla/avengers tells the story
of an epic clash between earth
mightiest heroes and the league who Duke
it out before teaming up to stop a
timeless evil jla/avengers could be the
superhero movie to end all superhero
movies but it's wampie not only with the
rights be a nightmare to untangle but
after a team-up like that there is
nowhere to go but down
thanks for watching click the looper
icon subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]